翻訳: Mariko Yamada
校正: Riaki Poništ
私はゴミ掃除の仕事をしています
ゴミはゴミでも 普通のゴミとは
ちょっと違うかもしれません
私がお掃除をする場所
それは宇宙なんです
こちらのシュミレーション映像を
ご覧ください
たくさんの点が地球の周りを
ぐるぐると回っています
このシュミレーション映像は
地球の周りにある人工衛星や
ロケットの数を表したもので
この赤い点は
今はもう使われていないもので
つまりはゴミということです
これらは何かというと
もう使われなくなった人工衛星や
ロケットの一部
ロケットは宇宙へ物を
運ぶ役割をしていますが
その一部は宇宙に残ります
そして爆発など 事故が起きて
生まれてしまった破片たち
私たちが空を見上げても
そんな景色は全く見えません
まさか この空の向こうが
ゴミだらけなんて
想像できるでしょうか
ですが事実
この宇宙のゴミ問題が
深刻な状況を作り出しているのです
地球を周回する物体は
時速７、８キロで移動しています
これは弾丸よりも速いスピードです
また 大きさはというと
ロケットの一部となると
大型バスくらいの大きさになります
一方で 砂つぶのように
小さな破片のものまであります
つまり大小さまざまな物体が
超高速で地球の周りを
飛び交っているということになります
さすがにこれだけの数があると
衝突事故って起きてないのかな
って思いませんか
実は起きているんです
2009年 アメリカとロシアの衛星が
軌道上で衝突事故を起こしています
この衝突によって
一万個以上の宇宙ゴミが
また新たに発生してしまいました
宇宙ゴミの脅威とは まさにこのことで
衝突によって生まれた破片が
また別のゴミに衝突して
また新たな破片を生み出す
そうやって その数がどんどん どんどん
増えていくということが
問題視されているのです
宇宙は遠い存在と
思われているかもしれませんが
実は みなさん日常的に
宇宙の技術を使っています
例えば
今日ここへ来るのに GPSなど
地図アプリを使って来ませんでしたか
そして朝は 天気予報を
確認してきたのではないでしょうか
ご自宅でBS CSのテレビを見ている方も
いらっしゃると思います
これらはすべて
人工衛星が可能にしています
また 航空や海上輸送などの
交通インフラ
金融取引やビジネスサービス
災害監視など
私たちの生活の基盤となるところには
人工衛星が使われています
なので もし 万が一
宇宙ゴミが衝突してしまったら
人工衛星はあっという間に壊れてしまい
今の私たちの便利な生活を維持するのは
とても難しくなってしまいます
そんな危機的な状況の中
世界中が何も
してこなかったわけではありません
10年以上前から NASAや
日本の宇宙機関JAXAなど
主要な宇宙機関や研究機関が
この宇宙ゴミの問題に
もう取り組み始めています
また 国連では
国際的な宇宙ゴミに関するルールを
作ろうとしています
ですが 世界中が集まって
ルールを作ろうとすると
政治的な問題 法律の問題
お金の問題 などなど
たくさんの問題が絡んで
なかなか前に進まないのです
このような状況の中で
民間会社がビジネスとしてやるからこそ
この停滞状況を打破できると考え
宇宙ゴミの掃除をする会社ができました
それが今 私が働いている会社です
さて
宇宙のゴミ掃除ビジネスを始めるのに
必要なものは何でしょうか
もちろん まずはお金ですね
そして 次は 技術
宇宙ゴミを回収する技術が必要です
３つ目 ビジネスモデル
よく 誰がお金出すんですか
って聞かれるんです
そして４つ目が 法整備
そして最後の５つ目が
宇宙のゴミ問題を
たくさんの人に知っていただくこと
これが一番重要だと思っています
この課題に取り組むのは
「スペース・スイーパーズ」
というチーム
なんか あの
ゴーストバスターズみたいですよね
（笑）
宇宙のゴミ問題は ５つの課題を
同時に解いていかなければならず
どれか一つが欠けても成立しません
この絵には 経営者からエンジニアまで
それ以外にも分野を問わず
全員が一丸となって
この問題に取り組んでいこうという
強い意志がこめられているんです
私はその中で
エンジニアと同時に
日本に製造開発拠点があるんですけど
そこの代表を務めています
大学から数えて約10年ほど
人工衛星の開発に関わってきました
私が主に担当していたのは
「構造と熱」という分野なんですけど
「構造」というのは
ロケットに人工衛星を乗せた時に
打ち上がって行って
その時の振動とか
荷重に耐えるように
ボディの設計をするというのが
お仕事です
で 「熱」というのは
宇宙ですと 太陽が当たっているのと
当たっていないところで
100度以上の温度差があります
なので そんな過酷な温度環境下でも
人工衛星の中の装置やセンサーが
ちゃんと動くように
程よい温度に保ってあげるという
設計をしなければならない
ということをやっていました
そもそも 私が人工衛星に
興味を持ったきっかけというのは
大学時代なんですけれども
人工衛星がアイディア次第で
たくさんのいろんな利用が
可能なんだということを
知ったからなんです
昨今では 面白いことに
人工衛星を使って 宇宙で
エンターテイメントを
しようとしているところもあります
で その中で私は
「宇宙ゴミビジネスをやりませんか」と
今の会社の創業者から
声をかけてもらった縁で
今ここにいます
私たちは
宇宙ゴミ掃除をするにあたって
２段階のアプローチを
考えました
１段階目は もうこれ以上
ゴミを増やさないこと
これからも人工衛星やロケットは
どんどん打ち上がっていきます
それらが もうこれ以上
ゴミにならないようにします
そして ２段階目は
今あるゴミの数を減らすこと
今すでに地球の周りにあるゴミを
回収していくというのが次のステップです
なぜ この２段階に
しているかというと
まず技術的に
この１段階目と２段階目
難易度が異なります
なので段階的な
ステップアップが必要となります
そして２つ目は
人工衛星の打上げ事情が
変化してきたからです
今 宇宙業界では
「コンステレーション」という構想が
大変盛り上がりを見せています
コンステレーションとは
数百から数千基の衛星を
地球全土を覆うように
等間隔に配置をして
一つの役割を果たすものです
このシステムが使えることが可能になると
例えば 地球上のあらゆるところで
インターネットが繋がるようになったり
あらゆる地域で
画像や様々な計測データを
高頻度に入手することができて
それによってたくさんの多くの産業への
支援が可能となります
ところで
このようなサービスを展開している
数百とか数千基の衛星のうち
１基が壊れてしまったとします
これはもう もちろん
ゴミということになるのですけれども
当然
壊れた衛星と新しい衛星を交換して
サービスを継続したいと思いますよね
でも その壊れた衛星が
動けないとしたらどうでしょうか
例えば レッカー車のようなものを使って
移動してあげることが
回収してあげることが必要です
そう 例えて言うなら
この宇宙ゴミ回収サービスというのは
車のロードサービスに
似ていると思います
壊れた衛星をその場から回収して
他の衛星が通る軌道が
安全になるように保たれます
また 宇宙ゴミは
そのまま何百年も
宇宙に留まり続けるので
積極的に回収することで
ゴミの増加を阻止することができます
宇宙のゴミ掃除方法は
とってもシンプルで
回収して 大気圏に落として
燃え尽きる というやり方です
どうやって回収すると思いますか
人が行って回収する
違います
ロボットで回収する
ちょっと近いんですけれども
なんか ガンダムみたいな
世界になりますか
（笑）
それも違うんです
私たちは 人工衛星で
ゴミ回収を行います
これは 宇宙ゴミ回収衛星
「ELSA（エルサ）」と言います
宇宙ゴミ回収の
一連の流れはこうです
まずエルサは ロケットによって
宇宙まで運ばれます
ロケットから切り離された後
衛星に搭載した
センサーを駆使して
ターゲットまで
わずか数十センチの距離まで
近づきます
近づいた後
びっくり箱のようなものが
にゅっと飛び出して
相手を捕まえます
この時 捕まえるところには
磁石が使われています
みなさん よくご存知の
ごく一般的な磁石です
なぜ 磁石を使っているか
宇宙は無重力なので
相手にちょん と押してしまうだけで
遠くに離れて行ってしまうんです
その点 磁石は相手の方から
引きつけられてくるので
衛星側で精密なコントロール
動きがいらず
その分 衛星側のシステムを
シンプルにできると考えています
宇宙ゴミを捕まえ
回収した後は
そのまま大気圏に突入して
燃え尽きるという計画です
すごく便利です
ゴミの分別も不要です
全部燃え尽きますから
（笑）
私は宇宙の映画やアニメで
描かれたような
未来の世界を見てみたいんです
もしかしたらそれは全く違ったものに
なっているかもしれませんが
そういうことを考えると
とっても わくわくしてきます
きっとそれは
多くの産業が
宇宙と結びついて
また宇宙が より多くの人にとって
身近なものになっている
と思うんです
これまで 宇宙開発というのは
国が主導で行ってきました
それを私は みんなのものに
したいと思っています
ただその前に
宇宙をきれいにする
ということが必要なんですね
私たちは 今この
エルサの試作機を開発中で
宇宙で技術実証をしようとしています
2020年にロシアのロケットで
打ち上げを計画しています
私たちの宇宙ゴミ掃除への取り組みは
まだまだ始まったばかりで
たくさんの困難にぶつかることでしょう
ですが 何もしないわけには行きません
なぜなら 地球の周りが
このようにゴミだらけになってしまったのは
100％ 私たち人間のせいなんです
宇宙がこれからも
持続的に利用し続けられるよう
宇宙環境を守っていくことが
私たちのミッションだと考えています
今日このお話を聞いていただいて
宇宙ゴミの問題に
関心を持っていただけたら
とても嬉しく思います
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）